bei mir ist jetzt ja nina kirsch unsere
unterhaltungschefin janina wir haben es
gerade schon gesehen das ist also die
umgebung in der der wendler in den usa
jetzt seine zeit verbringt weil er nicht
zurück nach deutschland möchte aber um
mal in deutschland zu bleiben er ist ja
nicht der einzige promi der hier mit
verschwörungstheorien mit verworrenen
corona theorien handhabt wie sieht das
mittlerweile in deutschland aus wer ist
das schon alles so getroffen wenn man
das so sagen möchte also der
prominenteste vertreter ist natürlich
immer noch veganen koch attila hildmann
darüber haben wir ja auch schon sehr
viel berichtet der ja auch wiederum sehr
viel kontakt mit michael wendler hat
zurzeit wie er selber sagt was aber
wirklich schlimm ist dass kollegen von
mir herausgefunden haben dass jetzt
wirklich gezielt auf prominente
zugegangen wird das bedeutet dass diese
gruppe von colon corona leugnen gezielt
versucht prominente zu rekrutieren und
auf sie zugeht das passiert in
verschiedenen arten und weisen das
passiert unter anderem durch mails oder
durch telefonanrufe und eine e mail
liegt uns zum beispiel auch vor das
schreibt ein absender der natürlich ein
fake namen benutzt weil keiner zugeben
möchte sage ich mal so wer da wirklich
hinter steckt an diverse musiker und ich
möchte daraus jetzt mal vorlesen da
stehen dann setzte drin wie bitte lassen
sie zu dass xxx diese e mail bekommt es
geht um mehr als karriere und geld es
geht um das ganze deutsche volk und und
um unser land und das sollte jetzt
wichtiger sein als karriere
wir brauchen dringend unterstützung von
den künstlern weiteren steht da xxx ist
so bekannt und hätte die macht das zu
stoppen und viele menschen endlich mit
wachzurütteln und ich glaube auch dass
sie wissen was hier in diesem land
gerade passiert und wie wichtig es ist
dies alles zu stoppen einmal zur
erklärung xxx haben wir natürlich jetzt
auch dahin geschrieben weil das gezielt
an diverse künstler geht das heißt wir
haben verschleiert werde jetzt direkt
angesprochen wurde aus quellenschutz
aber das ist halt die art und weise wie
jetzt versucht wird prominente zu
rekrutieren sagt im die namen
verschweigt man muss vielleicht auch
dazu sagen die fehler in diesen
nachrichten kommen auch nicht von uns
also die werden tatsächlich so
verschickt aber wenn man das jetzt so
hört oder liest eigentlich muss man
denken jeder der die mail bekommen denkt
sich ja ist klar und dann gelandet die
im papierkorb warum werden promis jetzt
vor allem so mit solchen e mails
bombardiert und vereinbaren wenn man
unbedingt promis dazu bringen sich jetzt
gegen die korona maßnahmen auszusprechen
das ist ganz klar das perfide spiel mit
der angst laut unseren informationen ist
es so dass vermehrt musiker
angeschrieben wurden die gerade sowieso
durch die korona krise finanziell
schlecht dastehen also gebeutelt sind
diese corona leute machen sich das zu
zeigen das heißt sie versuchen genau bei
dieser angst anzusetzen und zu sagen
mensch so kann es doch nicht weitergehen
ihr habt keine einnahmen
die maßnahmen sind alle völlig völlig
irre wirken alle nicht arbeiten wir
müssen was dagegen tun wir müssen uns
zusammen gegen die regierung
sozusagen gegen die regierung stellen
und genau da versuchen die natürlich
anzusetzen jetzt muss man sich
vorstellen wenn ein musiker lernen
terminkalender hat und vielleicht keine
auftritte keine einnahmen und so eine
wahnsinnige existenzangst hat dann sind
die natürlich in gewisser form auch
labil und damit dann auch leichte opfer
die andere seite ist natürlich dass das
prominente aushängeschilder so wie zum
beispiel der wendler natürlich
wahnsinnig viele fans am wahnsinnige
follower und die kuh roland leitner sich
natürlich freuen wenn ihre wahnsinnigen
und ihren theorien durch prominente
verbreitet werden eins möchte ich dazu
aber noch sagen wir reden hier nicht von
menschen die die einfach nur die
maßnahmen hinterfragen oder kritisieren
sondern wir reden von menschen die
wirklich einfach wahnsinnige und ihre
theorien verbreiten wie zum beispiel das
es gar nicht gibt oder auch dass wir
alle dass irgendwann ein bürgerkrieg
ausbricht oder dass wir irgendwelche
biochips unter die haut zur komplett
überwachung transplantiert bekommen also
es handelt sich hier nicht um reine
kritiker denn genau das soll natürlich
auf den sozialen netzwerken verbreitet
werden von den promis ein soziales
netzwerk das jetzt alle ganz besonders
beobachtet haben war natürlich auch das
von laura der der freundin der frau vom
wendler
die hat sich jetzt zum erstmal wieder
gemeldet wir können das 1
kurz zeigen es ist tatsächlich nicht der
atemberaubend wasser gekommen ist und
genau das ist eigentlich das
interessante an der ganzen sache weil so
still ist es sonst nie um laura oder der
laura folgt auf ihren instagram account
der weiß ganz genau dauerbeschallung von
morgens bis abends wird da irgendwas
gepostet private dinge aber natürlich
auch sehr viel werbung für pflege für
klamotten für lipgloss für alles
mögliche und das hat seit dem tag als
michael wendler mit seinen kruden
verschwörungstheorien auf sich
aufmerksam gemacht hat aufgehört
was natürlich dafür spricht dass auch
die werbepartner sich abgewendet haben
von laura das haben wir ja auch schon so
geschrieben und ich kann mir auch
vorstellen dass er natürlich einen
wahnsinnigen einfluss auf sie hat und da
auch wirklich die hand drauf hat
momentan das ist also abzuwarten wie das
ganze sich weiterentwickelt die beiden
noch immer in den usa wie wir gesehen
haben wollen erstmal nicht zurückkommen
aber wir werden uns natürlich weiter
beobachten auch in jedem fall
danke janina mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren